Speaker 1: Yesterday, when we looked at some
of the things said by people who went to the
Michigan Trump rally over the weekend, I missed
the clip. And it's really like the most important
clip. And so in a way it's good because it
won't get all mixed up in a slurry of insanity.
We'll just look at this one clip. This is
a video clip of a woman who went to the Trump
rally over the weekend, and she has a really
specific and really complicated conspiracy
theory about election theft, and she starts
by saying the election was stolen from Trump.
That's not super unique. There's millions
of these people who believe that the election
was stolen from Trump, but her explanation
is so out there that let's let's do this.
Let's play the clip. Try to listen specifically
to each of the points of the conspiracy, and
then we'll talk about them all at once in
a moment.
Speaker 2: The election, I believe, was stolen,
but we know that Space Force has it all. Trump
has all, all the information. It's going to
be overturned. What do you think? Space Force
as a Space Force is a military branch of the,
you know, just like the army, the, you know,
all the military and they literally walk up
here and they literally the night of the election,
they literally watched the election be stolen.
Now, you know, they watermark the ballots.
They know exactly what happened with every
ballot. They know what fake ballots. All right.
They saw they knew the election switches.
They know what countries were involved. They
know they follow the money. They know what
every politician that's been paid off. They
know there is. There was two hundred and sixty
thousand two hundred sixty nine thousand votes
sealed indictments, but I think it might even
be up to five hundred thousand sealed indictments.
And I believe that we're going to have an
emergency broadcast in the military is going
to come in with martial law and we are going
to be shown eight hours on, eight hours off
of videos for seven days the world. And they're
going to be showing us taped tribunals, tape
confessions and the world is going to be awakened
to what's really going on with the deep state.
Speaker 1: The election was stolen. OK, well,
I mean, that part's common, and I understand
what she's saying, but then the rest of it
doesn't really make sense. Space Force and
Trump have all the information. All right.
Well, I don't know why they would have information,
but I still follow it. It's going to be overturned.
Well, no, it's not. I mean, listen, we're
at the next election already. And if Biden
were removed for any reason, Kamala Harris
becomes VP, and if she is removed, then it's
Nancy Pelosi. So that doesn't really make
any sense at all. She says the night of the
Election Space Force watched the election
gets stolen. What does that mean? They watched
it like on TV, or they watched it as an institution,
she says. Space Force watermarked the ballots.
Why would Space Force do that? Space Force
is now involved in like printing. That doesn't
make any sense. How would Space Force watermark
ballots and then what would they do with them
after that? So now, I guess because of the
watermarking, Space Force knows everything,
including which countries are involved, which
was really like a wow kind of situation. She
says politicians have been paid off in Space
Force knows about it, and then it's completely
off the rails. And she adds that there were
two hundred and sixty nine thousand sealed
indictments. Two hundred and sixty nine thousand
people were about to be indicted for what
and Space Force knew about it. Why does Space
Force know about it? Wouldn't that be the
Justice Department? But maybe I'm asking too
many questions. And then the military would
come in with martial law after an emergency
broadcast. You know, that's like those beeps
that you hear. Like, this is a test of the
emergency. You know that thing they would
they would do that for hours and hours with
eight hours on and eight hours off of confessions
and tribunals conducted by whom and when.
I mean, none of it makes any sense. And here's
the real question about this is this actually
really, I want to hear what you really believe.
Is this actually a conspiracy theory that
this woman came up with and understands? Or
is this something that she misheard or misunderstood?
And what I mean by that is I will often get
emails from people misunderstanding everything
I say on this show. A couple of weeks ago,
someone wrote in and said, David, I would
be really interested in hearing about where
in. Belgium, your family's from. I've never
said my family's from Belgium. I said I've
been to Belgium. I said I liked it. I said
they have good chocolate. I never said my
family's from Belgium. Sometimes I say, Hey,
if you want a free membership, fill out a
form on my website. People email me, David,
I'm asking you to give me a membership. No,
I say I'm from Argentina and people say, Wow,
you're from Israel. Yeah, OK. So if even me
saying really simple stuff leads to this level
of misunderstanding, maybe this entire conspiracy
theory is not even really a conspiracy, really
a conspiracy theory she heard from someone
else. Maybe she misheard it and misunderstood
it. Either way, it's very, very scary. And
I don't see that turning around anytime soon,
and I'm starting to get people mad at me.
For a particular reason, people have been
mad at me for a while. I'm starting to get
people mad at me because they say, David,
you need to be proposing solutions to this
problem of radical Trumpists. I don't have
them, guys. I'm sorry. What I can tell you
is if we want to do one on one, it can be
hours, days, weeks to deprogram someone that's
hard to do at the wholesale level. So I don't
know that that's the solution when it comes
to forcing rapid kind of cultural change.
When rapid cultural change has been forced
in the past, it's been dictators. It was,
you know, the Cultural Revolution in China.
It was it's bad. So that doesn't seem good.
I'm not an authoritarian, so I can't say that's
the direction we should go. So I don't have
an answer. Yeah, fixing education, of course,
but I I don't pretend to be the expert with
all the answers. I am sort of at my wits end
with how we deal with these people. And you
may know just as much as I do. I happen to
be the guy with the mike. But we all need
to work together to figure
that out.